me and ki just hanging out look at that
face hi I'm Liam Payne and I'm here at
BuzzFeed and I am about to meet a lot of
puppies oh you're lovely aren't you
hello and you also want to join me this
one really likes me I've got an
attachment here all right then let's
answer some questions
[Music]
I think I would collaborate best with
Zayn because we do really similar type
of music and I would say that I would
like I music videos be right here with
these puppies because this is just too
much fun right now
there's talk of maybe doing
collaboration maybe I'm going to
collaborate with this guy right here and
but I can't tell you it is yet but she
is an artist okay it's very open isn't
it I love the question Bowl you you why
do you want to pick me a question you
will
what a question to follow up with that
question I would collaborate with Nicki
Minaj I think the best
my favorite part about touring with the
boys was when we were younger we used to
spend a lot of time together on the tour
bus when we did our first American tour
we had a really tiny small bus and it
was just a lot of fun and just hanging
out and it was like I don't know that
was the time when we got to know each
other best I think to write about
no I'm not at all I think honestly he's
really really suited to the job and I
know he's really good at why he goes and
I wanted to congratulate you - a massive
moment like being in a Christopher Nolan
action film like how amazing super cool
I haven't seen it yet but I am planning
on having a little event with my team
and some of my family and going down and
all of us watching it together because I
want to make sure that it's in a nice
set and I want to go have amazing cinema
and ages and I'd like I like go to the
cinema
you haven't said hello very much hello
hello the last text message I sent was
check the vids aha so one of my friends
because I was doing some city videos on
Instagram I was longer born there but
was it not very exciting there you make
sure you stay there the whole time here
is quite chill what's your deal
Pete you Evernote you the naughty one of
the words to me
[Music]
yes I think we will reunite at some
point in the future I'm sure we have to
I mean we've got an album that we
haven't even told you and I want to
write some more songs as well with the
boys the songwriting process has been a
lot different because you have to look a
lot inside yourself for inspiration it
was different when you were right I was
writing for the boys because you know we
are you have to have four people to do
so in a way it's quite easier as well
but it's hard because I know it's very
very it just relies on you ain't it it's
just nice and there's some really
personal songs I've done on that album
and there's some that are done by other
writers because there are obviously
great writers in the world and I've got
to work with some great people like
Pharrell and Ryan Tedder and obviously
Zedd at the moment which has been great
so I've been really lucky with the
people I got to work with yes at there
and know there's loads of different
parts to album so I'll probably be there
so tames um yeah and there's some
ballads there's some hip hop songs
there's some more dance music so I think
there's a really very mix of different
things that we have I don't know how I'm
ever gonna separate from you ever again
look at your eyes my go-to karaoke song
would be I know and now hot lime Linga
Hey but that can only mean one thing
there's actually a name for this and
it's a long something-or-other phobia
but yeah they're called I'm not sure but
I'm no longer afraid of spoons my
favourite songs
I think I'd like to go in and play
arenas I love a big stage I like running
around actually measured it one time
when we land stage we used to do like
six kilometers a night every time so I'm
so used to running around a big stage so
I don't know how I feel going back to
smile do you like it smaller than
usually likes nice and intimate but I
love to do like a really big shows and I
want to find a great show for you guys
with loads of different elements in
there so I would wake up at around 9 go
to the gym for a little bit I'd sit and
watch I'd have the new series of peaky
blinders out now that'd be a good day
I'm having to wait for ages I would have
an in-n-out burger because they are the
best thing known to man that would be
quite a perfect day oh you're back again
hello my favorite memory was when we
first did Madison Square Gardens we
popped up the floor and the crowd is
just applause wherever you go in we
popped out the floor it was just the
most amazing feeling ever knowing that
we were in Madison Square Gardens and
our album we just broke the record for
debuting at number one on the American
charts so that was a real fond memory of
mine how we doing Pete what's hang in
I would say having my mrs. irony is
always a nice thing selector and she's
always go I've always got my eye on her
I would say 'pete at this moment in time
is just fulfilling life for me I want to
say thank you to both fever have me
today but I just wanted to let everybody
know but all these puppies are adoptable
from the North Shore Animal League in
America so please if you have a good
home and you want a nice lovely puppy
like Pete go and get him and look at
peace oh my god Pete man you killing me
[Music]